all these guys who proclaim themselves
enthusiastic defenders of reason the
Enlightenment are simply a part of a
very long judeo-christian tradition and
they are unwilling to see in their own
faces the long tendrils stretching back
into antiquity
[Music]
hey hey welcome this is the Ben Shapiro
show Sunday special I'm excited to
welcome to the program
David Berlinski he's senior fellow at
the Discovery Institute Center for
science and culture
he's author of human nature as well as
the devil's delusion atheism and its
scientific pretensions and many more
books he stopt philosophy math English
at Stanford Rutgers City University of
New York University of Paris we have a
lot to talk about
that's all that in just one second but
first let me tell you I love my helix
sleep mattress why well because I sleep
up on it why do I sleep upon it because
it's extremely comfortable helix sleep
they've got a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper or a hot sleeper whether
you like a plush or firm bed with helix
there's no more confusion and no more
compromising helix sleep is rated the
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine just go to helix sleep comm
slash been take that two minutes sleep
quiz they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life I know because I took
that quiz with my wife it is
extraordinarily comfortable the mattress
for couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've got a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights at risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix is
offering up to 125 dollars off all
mattress orders for our listeners cap to
125 bucks off at helix sleep comm slash
Ben that's helix sleep comm slash Ben
for up to 125 bucks off your mattress
sword which is a heck of a deal helix
sleep comm slash Ben again that's helix
sleep comm slash Ben David thanks so
much for stopping by I really appreciate
it you're welcome so let's talk a little
bit about your book human nature that
the basic premise of the book is that
there are a lot of folks across the
political spectrum it seems who are very
invested in the idea that there is no
such thing as a fixed human nature that
humanity is intensely malleable and
completely malleable how pervasive do
you think that feeling is in in politics
these days I couldn't tell you about
politics but certainly as an
intellectual tendency I would put the
percentage of people prepared to deny
essentialism at roughly 99.999% leaving
a miniscule minority to affirm the
obvious yes there is some such a thing
as human nature obviously so and it's an
essential component
of being alarmed he explained for a
second what you mean by essentialism
because some folks who are watching may
not understand the philosophical term
when you say essentialism as compared to
other forms of philosophy what do you
mean well let's take a human being and
the question is are there any properties
such that those properties are
necessarily true of a human being in
virtue of his or her being a human being
one answer is no there are no essential
properties human beings are infinitely
flexible infinitely changeable
infinitely malleable the contrary answer
is yes there are a suite of properties
that necessarily define what it is to be
human being this thesis was part of
traditional philosophy it was rejected
in mid twentieth century philosophy it
was a very powerful attack launched
against essentialism and metaphysics
let's say Quine has a famous argument a
bicycle rider is essentially two-legged
but a mathematician is not but the
bicycle rider may be a mathematician
which of those properties are truly
essential it all depends on the way the
object is described that's a powerful
argument that's not a dismissable
argument the question is is it a valid
argument that's quite a separate
question why do you think there's been
this attack on essentialism what's the
purpose of the attack understand the
underlying purpose one is philosophical
which is quite independent of everything
else but the other is political after
all the governing axiom of the 20th
century has been human beings are
infinitely malleable and we who hold the
power are prepared to exert that power
to change them at will this is after all
what the essence of communism really is
an infinitely perfectible creature and
if it has to be perfected by brute force
were prepared to exert brute force for
the perfect ability of human beings
without that assumption many social
forms of 20th century life become
impossible we see that everyday in the
United States for example without the
governing assumption that we can change
human beings it will certain tendencies
are
completely impossible completely
impossible a human being is necessarily
self identical for example no one is
prepared to deny that is a man
necessarily a man or a woman necessarily
a woman that immediately provokes a
firestorm of controversy and indignation
the principle having been surrendered in
the case of self-identity is absolutely
incoherent on the other hand if you
maintain there are some necessary
properties of human being you are in
very weak polemical ground when you try
to draw the line say at sexual identity
or racial identity or at personal
identity so a lot depends on on the
intrinsic plausibility of the anti or
Pro essential argument a lot depends on
it it's not a trivial philosophical
issue as we both know and it's a very
very interesting very interesting
phenomenon that a relatively obscure
issue say analytic philosophy in the
1950s and 1960s had to be of tremendous
importance tremendous importance you
have to get the nuances just right no
one knows how to do it you've linked the
the attack on essentialism in some ways
back to the the wholehearted belief in
evolutionary biology and Darwinism the
idea that because human beings
supposedly evolved from prior species
and are evolving into future species
that there are no actual hard boundaries
around what constitutes a human nature
there's no such thing maybe even as a
human such thing as human nature there's
no such thing as a dog's nature either
if you're a committed believer in
Darwinian evolution because there's no
such thing
Oh fall at the bottom as a species how
could there be a species in Darwinian
terms Darwinian theory holds that there
are a continuum of animal forms which
gradually imperceptibly shape one into
the other the dividing line between the
dogs if you go back and back in time
doesn't end abruptly it merges into what
came before the dogs there's no point
where you can say that one is not a
but that one all of a sudden is a dog
that's anathema to Darwinian thinking
makes no sense and don't worry in turn
it happens to be true could you make the
argument if you're an evolutionary
biology defender you're Darwinian
defender could you make the argument
that sure over the course of time there
is evolution from one species into
another there's an origin to species and
then there's determined there's not
really a terminus of species it evolved
into further species but in any given
point if you stop the clock right now
and you looked at species you could
actually draw distinctions between the
species because you're not looking at
now a time bound phenomenon you're
looking at today you're not looking at
over the course of history one species
evolving into another you're just
looking at how to categorize things now
so could you accept the premises of
evolutionary biology and also accept
essentialism it's tough it's tough you
have to go through the contortions you
just underwent and that elegant sentence
you have to say let's stop the clock
let's look at objects as they are today
Friday at roughly 11 o'clock as soon as
we say but the theory of evolution is a
dynamical theory it's a theory about
what changes over time and you and you
search for a panoramic view of what's
happening over time that sense of sharp
boundaries necessarily must disappear
there is no room in Darwinian theory for
an essential view of the dog's nature
there's just no room for that you can
say right now short dogs or dogs and
people are people I could see the
difference sometimes good because don't
a hey you can see the difference but
that's not the theoretical question the
question is is that difference simply an
appearance an artifact of evolutionary
drama or is it something fundamental is
there something irrevocably doglike in
the dogs me I think there is so in your
book human nature you you launch a
series of attacks on widely read
evolutionary biologists and philosophers
and deconstructionist think that attacks
meditations harsh meditations on a
variety no not harsh harsh I reserve for
my friends
well you you talked about many of these
these philosophers and you are and it's
sort of an attack on the their attacks
on essentialism you it's it's it's it's
at least a a contemplation of their
attacks on essentialism from a variety
of angles and I want to go through some
of those shouldn't talk about exactly
what your critiques are so you begin the
book by talking specifically about
Steven Pinker the evolutionary biologist
at and sociologists over at Harvard
University his argument seems to be that
since the end of world war two that
really since the Enlightenment he has a
new book called enlightenment now in
which he argues that since the
Enlightenment human beings are getting
better we're constantly getting better
and this is reliant on our own ability
to change ourselves I have my own
critiques I find his argument both
incoherent and historically illiterate
in terms of his willingness to read out
of history some pretty awful things in
history that have happened over the past
few centuries but what is your what is
your chief argument with thinker well
let's put it this way in a in a certain
way I think Steven Pinker is absolutely
correct things have gotten better with
respect to certain parameters we live in
a time of great material abundance
perfect ease a good deal of domestic
tranquillity appearance is
notwithstanding antibiotics have been an
enormous success in medicine life
expectancy has inched up slightly it's
been a tremendous improvement with
respect to poverty in the third world
just astonishing improvement most of it
due to agricultural revolutions the
green green revolution all this is
unquestionable and I have no interest in
questioning it my interest in Pinker and
my critique of Pinker depends on what
historians call periods what is the
right period to assess the times in
which we live if it's yesterday I have
no argument whatsoever things were
pretty good yesterday they're pretty
good today Who am I to complain who is
humanity to complain the 20th century
though has not slipped into the past
very good English philosopher
Collingwood said that the chief goal of
20th century philosophy is to explain
the 20th century and we cannot do that
the 20th century is not part of the
species present we don't
live in the 20th century but the period
from 1940 to 1945 is extremely somber
and a full assessment of the times in
which we live must confront what took
place in Europe and the world during
those 30 years it was in fact a repeat
of the 30 Years War from 1618 to 1648 in
the 17th century it was the worst
century in human history in terms of
excess deaths but beyond any of that
terrible as those things were the 20th
century introduced a new principle into
political and social life a principle of
terror and we have not understood that
in any way we have failed completely or
even partially for example to grasp the
meaning of the Holocaust and to say well
things have improved since 1950
certainly true in certain measures and
ignore the rest of the 20th century
which is part of our living past as the
19th century no longer is seems to me a
profound historical mistake it is not a
serious kind of analysis my problem with
with Pinker that I've talked about in my
own book in it with regard to his view
of the Enlightenment is that it seems
incoherent in a couple of ways first he
dismisses religious background of the
Enlightenment as though it never existed
is that the Enlightenment sprang
full-blown out of people's heads with no
back our throat and that that that
foolishness he also tends to dismiss the
fact that the the Enlightenment that he
loved so much
also had to do with the French
Revolution which didn't go particularly
well and had to do with many of the
movements that would end up destroying
most of the globe in in the 20th century
as well meaning there's some pretty good
stuff about the Enlightenment namely the
American Founding the belief in human
freedom from government and all of us
and then there's some pretty dark things
about the Enlightenment as well there's
a dark sides in the Enlightenment when
you completely disconnect it from
eternal moral values and my problem with
Pinker is that all the stuff about the
Enlightenment that he requires to
actually be the gas in the tank for the
Enlightenment is the gas tank that he
has already emptied meaning he doesn't
like religion very much he thinks that
religion is wrong he doesn't believe in
free will but he relies greatly on the
idea that we can change ourselves and
that we have changed ourselves in line
with with higher philosophical thinking
he defines things like increase in human
flourishing by terms that would really
be relevant and
only two people who already believe in a
judeo-christian worldview and are
basically rejected by most of the rest
of the world
I find all of that that deeply troubling
in fact he engages in you might say the
exactly the form of essentialism that so
many people attend there are many
interesting things to say about the
enlightened which of course it's a very
complicated historical and philosophical
movement and European thought and it
can't be summarized too neatly but
Vivian Gornick writing in The New Yorker
reviewing a book by Primal levy who
survived Auschwitz she confronts the
experience of Auschwitz with all the
innocence of a woman who simply cannot
understand what she's discussing she she
says and I mentioned this in my book and
primer levy a child of the Enlightenment
could not grasp the fact that he was
being treated as he was and that phrase
a child of the Enlightenment the
particular incident that primal level
records was that he wanted to lick an
icicle he was so thirsty in this
concentration guard said no it's
forbidden and he and he said why the
home and the guard said here get this
kinda home which in German means there
is no why here he couldn't understand
that and neither do i I suspect could
you understand the driver and Vivian
Gornick simply says he was a child of
the Enlightenment he was baffled but the
question that never arises is why did
those enlightenment values prove
absolutely useless in the face of those
experiences why didn't they prevent
either side from committing the
atrocities I'm talking about they're
fascists in the Communist committing the
atrocities that they were so willing to
commit that's a question that Pinker
should have asked himself if he believes
so strenuously in the pre-salt
the power of Enlightenment ideas why
were they so useless
and why do they continue to be so
useless that's one question the other
question is the point that you raised
perhaps not a question a point I was
talking to Christopher Hitchens we got
together for just a few days and I said
when you look in the mirror
Kristopher to whom do you love that face
do you think was just created just for
you a special act of creation or is
there 2,000 years of the judeo-christian
tradition behind your face he didn't
have an adequate answer but he
understood above is getting at it
probable you didn't think it was a
particularly penetrating question but I
think it's a very penetrating question
of all these guys who proclaim
themselves enthusiastic defenders of
Reason the enlightenment the progress
the forward march of humanity the
infallible nature of their own moral
sentiments are simply a part of a very
long judeo-christian tradition and they
are unwilling to see in their own faces
the long tendrils stretching back into
antiquity and this is an historical
failure it's a failure of the
imagination
so you've famously critiqued
evolutionary Darwinism is your critique
more based on the science of
evolutionary terrorism or based on the
misuse of evolutionary Darwinism as a as
a sort of catch-all for explaining human
behavior and a catch-all for explaining
human change which would be the more
advantageous answer on my part which
would trigger a spontaneous burst of
enthusiasm in you I suspect it's both
and that's the real answer it's both
it's a scientific critique and let's be
honest there's not a whole lot of
science there by the standards of the
serious sciences and it's a critique of
the way evolutionary theory is used I
think both are important don't forget
the Nazis were great admirers of
evolutionary theory they adapted it to
their own purposes but there's a clear
connecting link between what Darwin was
saying in the middle of the 19th century
and what Himmler was proclaiming in the
middle of the 20th century first three
decades of the 20th century they
believed in evolution they believed in
evolution very sincerely that just
happened to believe evolution culminated
in a master race could have happened
another way at the end of the war Hitler
said well he made a mistake about the
master race it turns out to be the
Russians not the Germans superior people
of the east that's a quotation but you
can see these ideas churning again and
again I mean what gave the Nazis that
sense of entitlement that they were
allowed to exterminate other people they
didn't say it was a whim you look
through the entire literature about Nazi
Germany read what these guys were saying
and so they never said well we got
together at the Von's a conference we
decided be a good idea to kill all the
Jews I didn't say was just a good idea
to kill the Jews we need to kill the
Jews because they are parasitical on the
body politic the imperatives of a
purified biology demand their
elimination that's what they said where
did they get those ideas from well you
can go from 1859 every single generation
German biologists and doctors and
physicians and social workers were
saying the same thing first they got rid
of the mentally ill the infirmary
crippled the labored and then they went
on to the Jews and they would have kept
going on this is the sinister thing
about Nazism that very few people
understand then Nazis weren't going to
stop with the Jews they were going to
continue with the Slavs and when when
they had finished with the Slavs the SS
wanted to stall on the Germans this is
not well known at the end of the process
only the SS would remain that's the real
goal the Nazi state they had no
hesitation at all about a policy in
which the German people themselves would
be put to that test no doubt about that
or law so in a second I want to ask you
about your scientific critique of
evolutionary biology but first maybe
you've thought about investing in some
different assets like for example
cryptocurrency well that might sound
scary but all crypto really is is just a
solid asset meaning that it's not going
to be something that is manipulated by
governments cuz government doesn't
control it's protected by a blockchain
you invest in it and then the value is
determined by how many people are buying
into and out of the crypto market not by
centralized governments with different
interests so for example last week China
devalued its currency and the markets
tanked one consequence was that Bitcoin
prices rose well it's time to seriously
consider including some crypto in your
portfolio just like gold or real estate
you should diversify the best place to
trade crypto is eToro eToro is smart
crypto trading made easy eToro social
trading platform has over 11 million
traders the
facilitate over 1 trillion dollars in
trading volume per year globally you can
access the world's best cryptocurrencies
they've got 15 different coins available
they've got low and transparent fees you
can try before you trade with a virtual
portfolio with $100,000 budget so you
actually get to try this thing out and
see how it works never miss a trading
trend with charts and pricing alerts
crypto it's worth trying out check it
out right now
at eToro comm slash shapiro that's et o
ro dot-com / shapiro eToro comm /
shapiro so let's talk about your
critique of evolutionary biology this is
what's gotten an enormous amount of
attention from the private sector and
every time somebody steps out of line
with the with the sort of catechism of
evolutionary biology they're immediately
hit with a wave of you don't believe in
science you're actually just a religious
fanatic now your secular you're a
secular Jew as you say and we'll get to
that in a little while but what's your
biological or scientific critique of
evolutionary biology in a nutshell
presumably mm-hmm or do we have lots and
lots of time and we have plenty of time
but but you can nutshell it natural look
you've got evolutionary biologists who
say things like evolution is as assured
as the law of gravity but you never hear
a physicist saying the theory of gravity
is as assured as the theory of evolution
why is that well in a nutshell my
critique or my my suggestion is that by
the standards of the serious sciences by
the serious sciences I mean mathematics
the rich and comparably rich body of
mathematical science and the great
theories of physics Newtonian mechanics
Clark Maxwell see the electromagnetic
field special and general relativity and
quantum mechanics and quantum field
theory there is simply no point of
comparison evolutionary theory is vague
its incoherent its unarticulated its
imprecise it doesn't exist in any kind
of rigorous or serious form it's a
series of folktales
some very interesting I like watching
those programs on television as much as
you do no no the elephant mating habits
mating habits of the elephant that sort
of thing the seals the Antarctic but
that doesn't answer any of the many deep
questions that said of course there are
parts of evolutionary theory that are
perfectly respectable because they make
local observations undoubtedly true
certain certain things seem to have a
survival value you don't see a lot of
albino antelopes wandering around the
African desert for the obvious reason
they get eaten up right away by the
Lions a lion born without teeth or claws
needing dentures in a big way it is not
up to be a successful life only we can
all agree on that that sort of stuff but
if I ask a little more penetrating
question why for example I'm asking you
this aren't pigs born with wheels
mounted on ball bearings you don't know
either
ask an evolutionary biologist while
they're no roads yeah that's about the
standard of exploration you get in
biology and the questions are very real
we can we can see the questions it's a
very interesting distinction if I may
just go on for a second when we turn to
the mathematical or theoretical physics
the models are not terribly interesting
I mean let's be honest anybody really
interested in the universe or the Stars
or the galaxies or black holes no matter
how many times their parent television
with gestures of astonishment I always
turn off the toot and switch to
something else as soon as one of those
Nova shows comes on but the theories are
wonderful they're rich complicated
rhubarb ative the full of speculation
you turn to biology the theories are
primitive but the models of fascinating
everyone wants to watch kitten videos on
YouTube me too I like to see them too
so there's this radical disjunction
between what's interesting in physics
which are the theories and what's
interesting in biology which are the
organisms and there seems to be a
symmetry at work we have very very rich
theories and physics and very poor
theories in biology and that seems to me
a fact that needs to be appreciated
so you've suggested in the past that you
are not in advocate of intelligent
design and whenever somebody is
critiquing evolutionary biology that
immediately hit with well that's just
because you're a Bible believer who is
trying to invest the meaning of the
Bible in science but you say that you're
not a believer in intelligent design
where do you stand on that on the theory
of intelligent
believer and a whole lot of things I
think in intelligent design certainly
should have a seat at the table and it's
a serious idea it's a very old idea it
goes right back to antiquity that's for
sure
it's an idea that at first blush seems
to confront the facts successfully look
biological structures do appear as if
they were not only intelligently
designed but brilliantly designed now
you take a look at any biological system
the level of complexity is so daunting
as to be indescribable we haven't we do
not have a theoretical description of
any level of biological complexity
including the cell seems to be a closely
cause system that behaves in very
mysterious ways influenced by the
organism as a whole the organism as a
whole influenced by its cellular
structure we don't have a good grasp of
that you know there's an interesting
Institute just opening at ha not Harvard
Oxford for the mathematical study of
evolutionary dynamics and it begins with
the admission we don't have a
mathematical theory of evolutionary
dynamics 150 years after Darwin that
seems to me a striking admission these
are one of the the kind of anecdotes you
come across an evolutionary thinking
again and again and again the theory is
perfect it's irrefragable it can't be
corrected it's the summit of human
achievement but we're going to go right
back to the beginning and see whether we
can make it better and nobody nobody
seems that the Institute Oxford opening
up for the study of mathematical
dynamics and evolutionary thought how
come you guys didn't think about 100
years ago where were you then and if it
doesn't exist yet how can you say the
theory is as good as general relativity
it can't be that good and that's part of
the sociology the current sociology
you must remember that evolutionary
thought Darwinian thought is supported
by immense and powerful lobby it's it's
not only a scientific agenda but it's a
political agenda he who controls the
education in terms of evolutionary
theory has a very powerful advantage the
idea that these people are motivated
entirely by the fear that right wing of
an evangelical Christians are going to
seize the reins of power and imprison
women and other
and force a biblical regime on the rest
of us that's just wishful thinking so
what is the agenda that's connected to
the sort of attempt to dominate the
field and prevent anybody else from
asking questions well there is a status
ranking within the academic world I'm
sure you know about at the very top of
the mathematicians right now at the very
top cuz they're smarter and then let's
just admit it for among friends very
very few people are interested in
mathematics and fewer still can do
mathematics just slightly below the
physicists the physicists will have
another view they think they're above
the math it's neither here nor there in
the ranking the status ranked in the
evolutionary biologists away below the
molecular biologists at least they go
into the lab and do something so there
is a strenuous desire for an enhancement
of prestige that runs right through
evolutionary biology and when you get
some guy coming out and saying well I've
just read Leviticus and I have an
objection to evolutionary thought that's
an infringement on prerogatives you can
understand that it's very common used
car salesmen suffer from the same kinds
of affliction I don't think there's
anything surprising about that what I do
think is surprising is the success with
which the evolutionary biologists have
co-opted the media worldwide into acting
as an extended propaganda arm for
Darwinian theory that's really
remarkable it's it's it's somewhat
better now than it was say ten years ago
it's improving the climate is improving
because people are not indefinitely
gullible you know the common reaction to
the idea that it's brilliant blaze this
efflorescence of complexity we see in
the by all biological world is random
variation in natural selection most
people say you got to be kidding right
that's not the explanation a few facts
fits a few facts but there must be a
profound level of explanation with
respect to life we don't even know why
such a thing exists in the universe
which is otherwise bleak boring and very
big to get this bleak boring very big
place and you've got the earth
remarkable right
why is
there is this something in the nature of
chemicals that induces within a chemical
arena a desire to form something as
noble and as lovely as yourself does
anyone really believe that is it's the
outworking of a chemical blind chemical
process or a blind physical process it
may well be I'm not speaking
authoritative Lee in that I don't know
but it doesn't seem likely this seems
some level of explanation is called for
and we cannot even successfully express
the problem we just feel it life is
mysterious life is grand life is
magnificent life is full of mystery but
what's really the scientific way of
stating that the mathematically precise
way of saying that we know that life
seems to have all evolved in an uphill
direction from every point of view but
beyond saying that it's like a little
little bit about language you and I are
talking in English could be talking any
other language and the question that
most linguists will not ask is why is
there a language and why do human beings
possess a language and no other species
what good is a language I don't give me
a lot of complicated stories about
survival advantage we could cooperate
and hunting wildebeest or something like
that that's that's beneath us we're not
going to indulge in that kind of
childish fantasy but it is a fact human
beings have a suite of properties which
are very mysterious what good does
language do what good is mathematics do
so we can count one two three and we
know it the numbers go on so why is it
there why is it there my dog can't count
cats can't count that's really
remarkable you think about a cat
quarter-inch more cortex or an opposable
thumb they would rule the world but they
can't account the story that you hear so
often from folks who are we've
interviewed many of them on the program
who are who are big advocates of the
idea that evolutionary biology explains
morality it's always well you know I
grew up in a home where people sometimes
read the Bible sometimes not and then I
stumbled upon evolutionary biology and
explained everything and and that that
shifted my worldview and it seems the
governing
to stumble it seems it seems more remote
from broader perspective as though the
the actual motivating factor is not
adherence to evolutionary biology but
adherence to atheism meaning that once
you've decided that God can't be any
part of the picture
you now have to reduce everything to
pure scientific materialism once you've
reduced it to pure scientific
materialism you're now forced to reduce
all of the essential that you say
aspects of human nature down to
nothingness like actually just read them
out of human existence that that
consciousness is a myth that free will
is a myth that language is basically us
clicking at each other for purposes of
being able to form large social groups
that love is simply a biochemical
reaction that we've now become the the
drunk stumbling underneath the lamppost
for the car keys and if the car keys
aren't there then I guess we decide that
the car keys never existed in the first
place
well I think you should never under MIT
underestimate the attraction of a
primitive worldview I mean if it is
tedious to develop a sophisticated world
view simply appealing to Darwinian
theory as a justification for your
anterior prejudices there's a very
successful strategy the idea that there
is a kernel indubitable kernel by which
we can explain the panorama of human
moral decisions emotional decisions
commitments and that it has to do with
reproductive success is abysmally
primitive isn't it I mean there
certainly there is a connection between
reproductive success and the flourishing
of certain patterns and behavior nobody
doubts that but the full grandeur of
human life is certainly far bigger far
greater far more significant scope than
anything that can be explained in terms
of the desire the vagrant male desire to
get late isn't it we all know that it's
not an explanation it's part of a a much
larger picture so what do you see as the
essential features of human nature we've
talked about why it
wrong for people to reject that there
are essential features of human nature
but what do you think are the actual
essential features of human nature the
ancients would say reason you say in the
book that it seems like that has gone by
the wayside in recent decades when you
look at a human being what what is it
that that we all ought to be looking at
as the as the feature that unifies us
all I'm not sure I have an answer that
that would commend itself to your
attention but I think that it's a great
mistake to overlook original sin dr.
Johnston was asked for a defense of the
doctrine of original sin by his
biographer and he said concerning
original sin the inquiry is not
necessary because men are so avowedly
and confessedly corrupt that all the
laws of heaven heaven and earth are
unable to prevent them from the
commission of their crimes I think
that's something that should be
remembered especially anyone paying
attention to the 20th century not only
the 20th century the horrors slop over
into the 21st century as we all know
what's taking place in the Middle East
right now is not an exuberant
demonstration of enlightenment value
surely you agree I know you do I would
say that any any view of human nature
the essential human nature cannot
entirely be optimistic it must be
balanced certainly human beings are
extraordinary many ways essential
aspects of human beings I cannot imagine
human beings without a language and I
have no explanation for the fact that
they possess a language I cannot imagine
human beings without a profound ability
to love one another that's certainly a
part of human life and I cannot imagine
human beings without the capacity to be
miserable misfits unpleasantly violent
individuals
I cannot imagine human life without the
separation of the sexes into two
distinct genders yes two distinct
gentlest I'm the last traditional
upholder of the gender binary you can
count on that and these are all part of
what I would regard as a traditional on
standing of human life in human nature
and I think if you want a very rich
explanation you go to the novelists go
to Dostoyevsky you've got a Tolstoy code
again you've got a James Joyce go to
Thomas Mann they'll tell you what the
essential aspects or they speak with
pretty much the same voice do they're
not why do you think it is that so many
scientists have put themselves in the
service of what appeared to be overtly
anti rational anti science positions to
take the perfect example the rejection
of the gender binary the suggestion that
a man can become a woman a woman can
become a man that everybody exists on a
gender spectrum the gender is entirely
disconnected from biology all of these
premises are on their face logically
self-defeating they contradict each
other in a variety of ways they do not
hold together as a cohesive whole and
yet you will see people who purport to
be scientists either overtly say that
the science ought to be ignored
we've had people do that on this program
or proclaim loudly that the science
actually backs this idea even though
they have yet to provide any study that
suggests that gender is separate from
from biology they're idiots that's my
explanation and that's a remarkably
widespread successful explanation isn't
it even if there's a wonderful wonderful
proverb in German gagging dee dum hi
Kempton the obscure to forget wish which
means against stupidity even the gods
are helpless is there anything that you
would reject in that rebuttal I mean
just to take the devil's advocate view I
guess the Dee the most humane devil's
advocate view would be if they have no
other solution for whatever gender
dysphoria they are suffering with my
sort of libertarian sensibility suggests
you're an adult do what you want if
that's the best solution for you to live
your life according to you have at it
but you seem to object to that not
completely completely I share none of
your libertarian persuasions in that
regard I think society has a duty to
enforce certain taboos certain in
certain respects the health of the whole
demands in many respects this is the the
fact that certain individuals cannot
satisfy all of their desires
it's very unhappy but we're all in that
position we all obey the rules of
society in some respect or other
somebody who has a tremendous
desire to wear women's clothing that's
fine we used to call it transvestitism
nobody really objects to a man who wants
to wear a dress every now and then the
question is the justification in society
itself has now reached a transcendental
stage where metaphysical issues are put
into play it's not that certain men
would like to wear a dresses it is that
they are claiming a philosophical
entitlement to be considered women
legitimate now I agree with that I mean
that the change of the you've given that
a fairy on principles so quickly
although then no because libertarianism
to me has to do much more with the the
government intervention or the idea that
I'm going to control the behavior so you
sound libertarian when it comes to you
know women and men can wear dresses I'm
sure again that's about as far as I go
right I'm just saying that they're not
women so I think we may agree on that
yeah it's the it's the idea that you are
proposing before that I mean would you
be in favor of government stepping in
and preventing transgender surgery for
adults at once see that this is where we
have a distinction I would not know not
only that any physician who values the
Hippocratic oath should participate well
I agree with that but it's when you get
into the the government forcing adults
not to engage in behavior that has no
externalities that I have a problem with
why because once the government can
participate in forcing behavior that has
no externalities then there is no
limiting principle sure so well you
slide into tyranny pretty quickly that
way it seems true but you haven't given
me an argument yet I mean I understand
the sentiment but I don't think there's
a serious argument behind the sentiment
yet but but the point is it need not be
a government decision but a social
decision for example in terms of the
aims of structural violation and taboo
and what we're seeing now in the West is
a crumbling of any number of taboos some
silly but some very important we talked
about transgender issue but equally
interesting and very little discussed is
for example the ancient taboo against
tattooing which I find fascinating I
mean they're people now covered from
head to foot and tattoos and flaunting
them proudly and I must be the only
person left in the Western world who
remembered when that was a class marker
and it wasn't considered a commendable
class marker only primitives who
repaired automobiles more tattoos now
it's a sign of of a certain kind of
social refinement which is very
interesting you see the taboo crumbly
that's not terribly important who cares
of women are covered from head to foot
in tattoos you don't have to get near
them if you don't want but one tattoo
crumbles in one part of the social world
another tattoo crumbles and another
taboo crumbles in another part of the
social social world and the structure
far from being free of taboos puts the
taboos in a different place for example
free speech I don't know whether you're
aware of it but free speech is
relentlessly under attack I see that you
are aware of it well the ancient taboo
that you have no right to impede
someone's free expression of his or her
own ideas that's now crumbling in the
name of a defense against hate speech
I'm the last defender of hate speech in
the Western world by the way I'm all in
favor of hate speeches you may have
learned from reading my book but the
taboo goes up in one place it crumbles
in another place so in a second I want
to ask you about your your own religious
perspective because you call yourself a
secular Jew I'm an Orthodox Jew some
very curious about this but first here's
the fact hackers are becoming more and
more sophisticated you don't have to be
on public Wi-Fi anymore for somebody to
steal your information and if you've
ever had your information stolen tis no
fun like let's say that someone stole
your credit card information about a
bunch of NFL tickets which happened to
me well then you'd probably want to
start using expressvpn protect your data
with expressvpn i've been talking about
expressvpn on my show for so long you
already understand why encrypting your
network data is important but some of
you still have not acted why well maybe
you're thinking security threats don't
affect you personally this would be the
wrong way of thinking about it not using
expressvpn it's like leaving your front
door unlocked every time you go out sure
nothing might happen for years but when
a break-in does occur it's devastating
one of the easiest ways to secure your
Internet data is with expressvpn you
click one button on your computer or
your smartphone and you are
protected I'm using expressvpn myself
for years you should too my only
question is why haven't you gotten
expressvpn yet visit my special link
right now expressvpn comm slash men get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free protect your internet today with
the VPN I trust to keep my data safe go
to express VPN calm slash Ben to get
started ok so let's talk about your own
religious viewpoint so you've taken what
sounds like the perspective that I mean
you've cited to original sin you've
cited to religious principles that that
precede ancient religious principles
that precede up the enlightenment by
several thousand years um what's your
own religious perspective you mean in
terms of my own religious practice well
practice and belief practice there is
not light up I'm tempted to say
unfortunately it's not entirely a any
kind of decision that's under voluntary
control as you must know in my own case
any any endeavor or attempt to come
closer to either a religious way of life
or a religious experience has been a
failure I say in one of my books I
forgot which one I cannot pray although
I haven't made a very assiduous effort
of Prayer either I gave it a few tries
didn't get what I was asking for and
gave it up as a bad deals that may be a
shallow a meretricious point of view but
nonetheless it has been governing in my
life so I can't say that my life has
been a particularly flamboyant
exhibition of religious commitment on
the other hand I'm very intrigued by
religious ideas and I take them as
seriously as I take anything which may
not be as seriously as you would wish
but I do take them seriously because I
think there is a certain profundo T a
level of truths and religious doctrine
which cannot be expressed in my
preferred terms say mathematically or in
terms of a scientific theory but which
is nonetheless very resonant of knowing
no comparable words to express in the
beginning was the word that seems to be
a profound truth in some way if I could
tell you more about that
profound truth I would but I can't so I
won't but on that level I think religion
and the religious religious writings of
mankind are a tremendous source of
richness tremendous when you look at the
future of the civilization where
religion seems to be falling away in
droves I mean this is this is really the
pattern of the West really since the
Enlightenment but accelerating in the
aftermath of world war two and nihilism
became the way of the world do you see
any any future for for Humanity
regaining its sanity because in the
absence of some of the religious
principles you've talked about including
the essentialism of human nature it
seems like we may be sliding inevitably
toward a morass that is gonna be worse
than then things are now I would like to
give you a very sophisticated answer but
I don't think I'm able to in all of
these discussions it's terribly
important to remember that what we
talked about the slide into an
ill-defined morass of primitive
relativism and moral self-indulgence
decadence beastial indulgence of the
appetite as the Arab scholar al-ghazali
remarked is only a local a transient
phenomena in the West there are a
billion people out there who take the
Muslim faith very very seriously and
they seem largely to be exempt from the
secularizing trend that we're talking
about and that's a it's a fact that
should be kept in mind we talk about the
decline of religious beliefs say in the
United States it's far advanced in
Europe but it's not a worldwide
phenomenon by any means and I can't
speak with any degree of authority about
Chinese religious practices or Buddhist
religious practices but that's why you
got Sam Harris on doesn't he talk about
that stuff oh yeah he's a Buddhist I
think he believes in merging his mind
with the eternal cosmos or something
like that me that doesn't interest me
particularly but I would be very
skeptical about the forthcoming
elimination of what is plainly an aspect
of human life that is an interest a
curiosity a commitment to transcendental
values that go beyond the finite life
time of each individual so that does
raise the question is whether the future
of humanity is gonna come from or a
decent future for Humanity is going to
come from either a revivification of
some sort of religious understanding in
the West or whether it's going to come
from some sort of rebirth thing of
enlightenment in other parts of the
world early Islam was obviously a lot
more tolerant and open-minded toward a
dissension than then Islam has become oh
do you see a liberalisation in more
religious parts of the world or a Reeve
of the vacation of religion in more
liberal parts of the world as sort of
the direction that you'd perceived I
would ask to be forgiven for not
answering that question because I don't
know how to answer it I can tell you
that I do believe that what we're
undergoing now in the West say France
Germany Sweden to a certain extent Spain
possibly Italy in the United States is a
transient phenomenon I would strongly
encourage you not to bet against the
Roman Catholic Church simply because
it's been around for 2,000 years most
successful bureaucracy in all of
recorded human history don't place your
bets against it but what what human
beings will discover when they are
profoundly disappointed by schemes of
artificial intelligence or personal
immortality or merging their intellects
with a an apple laptop that remains to
be determined I am very skeptical about
those ameliorative schemes for the
future artificial intelligence or my
machine you've been very critical I mean
the book a very critical of the sort of
the futurists who who foresee this sort
of thing a very critical of Evo Harare
and his discussions of the the future of
humanity being inside your laptop as you
say why is that well if you if you go
back to 1912 and you you were would ask
a sophisticated observer of the European
scene what he would see in the next 50
years the last thing on earth he would
have predicted was the first world war
the interregnum the second world war on
the Holocaust and there and the rise of
Soviet Communism they were not on the
event horizon to take a few technologic
a few technological civilities things
that seem to work in an interesting way
like a computer and say this is the
future of the human race seems to me
abysmal it is it is such a terribly
narrow point of view it's again to come
back to the analogy used of a drunk
looking for his keys under the lab lock
because that's where the light is it's
not where the keys are we can do certain
things technically now that are
interesting there's no question that
they're interesting no question that
artificial intelligence deep learning
they're very interesting but whether
they answer the right kinds of questions
or whether we know what the right kind
of kinds of questions really are that
remains to be determined I'm very
skeptical what they do I think the
technology is being used because it's
usable exactly the same reason I use a
portable telephone which I happen to the
test
you've taught in major universities all
around the United States and these sort
of deep ideas that you're talking about
here on the program don't get taught at
all at these universities in fact they
are held in wide disdain at the
universities what happened to the
universities why are the universities
the way that they are do you think you
know I've been asking that question
again and again and I wish I could give
you a coherent or a real real answer
because what's been happening is a major
tragedy in American life and it's also
happening in English universities that's
for sure
for some reason with the no say 2025
years one of the noblest American
institution institutions has been
absolutely gutted revealed to be hollow
at its core the principles that had
supposedly defended not defended at all
for example free speech free inquiry
free exchange of ideas the relationship
between the faculty and students
completely turned transmogrified so the
students are now calling the shots the
serious intellectual commitments outside
of the core disciplines say physics and
mathematics rendered entirely
insupportable and nonsensical and a huge
administrative cohort largely female
dominated interestingly enough imposing
a kind of dreary idle ideological
conformity on the universe
city itself which no self-respecting man
would wish to have any part of but why
all this this happened I don't know I
saw it happening in the 60s you'll
forgive me for boasting of my age it
used to drive me crazy when my father
did that but now I find it just superb
equal much an address you was young
fella you don't remember the 60s you
couldn't but I was a senior figure in
the sixties that was born 40 to 45 which
was slightly before the baby boomers and
I saw the collapse of institutional
Authority at Berkeley at Stanford in the
Columbia and at Columbia these were
people I deeply admired like Dean David
Truman in the face of student protests
he just collapsed he didn't know what to
say he didn't know how to defend himself
and that's true I think throughout the
American university system the people
who should be defending the universities
did not know what to do
I remembered Columbia they ransacked the
university I was right there they went
into the president's office helped
themselves to his cigars
a good idea at the time I thought drank
his brandy scuffed up his table and
caused a riot and I was outside on the
street and speaking to some of the
faculty I admired like Sidney Morgan
Buster professor of philosophy and he
said his great anxiety was that the
university would call in the police
and I said Sidney that's what they're
for there's a riot go Club them on the
head drag them out by the heels that's
what the police are for making mock of
uniforms that guard you while you sleep
that's what you're doing right now and
you couldn't you couldn't see the point
he was willing to be a part of the
collapse of authority we've seen the
collapse of authority across the board
scientific Authority we talked a little
bit about transgenderism but also
intellectual and institutional authority
the university has a right to defend
himself is the right to call the police
and get rid of the miscreants why not
let's talk about the statement that you
made that you're in favor of hate speech
so I know my own defenses of hate speech
my own defenses of hate speech is that
that is a principle that does not exist
there again there's no limiting
principle to what you decide is hate
speech hate speech can be anything you
disagree with and
and historically has been used for
exactly that rationale what's your
what's your attack on hate speech well I
don't have an attack on hate speech I
rather like it it invigorates me to find
a good hater and I always have more
faith in a good hater than I do in a
mealy-mouthed individual but remember
the great lines
Robert Frost some say the world will end
in fire some say ice from what I've
tasted of desire I hold with those who
favor fire but if it had to perish twice
from what I know of hate I think that
ice is also great and would suffice you
know you have to make a principled
argument about the emotions or the
attitudes in order to justify the
suppression of speech on the grounds
that expresses hate and there is no such
thing remotely as a principled argument
for example to justify the claim that
certain crimes are hate crimes very
often an attack will be promoted in
seriousness on the grounds that the
person doing the attacking was hateful
well obviously he was attacking somebody
he must have disliked them but ok volge
on the other hand suppose he was
attacking and he was suffused with a
loving sense he just simply wanted
lovingly to Club someone into the
urine-stained pavement would that be a
lesser crime now you need to make you
you need to make that argument if you
believe seriously in hate speech to look
into sort of the divide between right
and left in the United States right now
what do you think is the the most
threatening you speak about you know
these very deep issues of philosophy I
don't think anybody in the United States
actually understands these issues of
philosophy it seems like everybody's
arguing on the surface of the iceberg
and yet is is very angry about all this
how much do you think people even
understand the issues that they're
arguing about not at all but the remedy
law is close at hand I would encourage
everyone within sound of my voice to
repair to their bookstore and see what
the truth really is between the covers
of a paperback edition that having been
said
the question really is an interesting
one I don't think there's ever been a
time maybe 18th century France to a
certain extent which is that's some
suggestive parallels where a series of
abstract idea seems to have percolated
downward into popular consciousness for
example essentialism gender rights
transgenderism hate speech I mean
there's a very long litany in a very
long list and become animating
principles people act on them if
somebody is convinced that you for
example or an advocate of hate speech
god forbid me I deplore hate speech as
you well know they're apt to act on it I
dare say you've been in some way
affected by that and I really don't know
exactly your background but I suppose
that people try to stop you from
speaking no yes it was so last night at
Stanford yes something like on the
grounds that you're a hate-filled or
you're to use the rhetorical phrase
that's badly of it over you spewing hate
I don't know why these strange
physiological terms of entered fun you
cannot express it you have to spew hate
as if it's a rainbow are like projectile
vomiting I observed when I worked in a
hospital and only the only something
that vigorous is adequate to the degree
of distemper that hate speech provokes
and of course it has nothing to do with
the content whatsoever it's just a
convenience aikka logical psychological
strategy but if you look at say France
from 1791 to 1794 you look at the
periodicals that were being published
left and right everywhere in Paris not
so much in the provinces but in Paris
the same sort of thing cheap
Enlightenment ideals about citizenship
and the rights of citizenship the
abolition of the feudal system and the
destruction of the clergy had percolated
downward to the level of common bromides
and people acted on that they acted very
very effectively chiefly by killing a
lot of people which is what happens
one of the little known facts about the
French Revolution it was the first
serious genocide in in Europe since the
end of the 17th century that is in the
Vaughan day which is the southwest
region of France estimates now about
40,000 people were killed in an act of
genocide specifically killed and many
more those estimates by the way go up to
a quarter of a million but it's very
hard to make sense of the estimates and
many many aspects of the French
Revolution are quite similar to things
that are taking place today in terms of
the rhetoric the propaganda the level of
indignation this synthetic anger most
anger that we experience the United
States or in Europe is synthetic it's
the product of a confection it's like
taking in an egg white and beating it up
it may increase in volume but not in
substance what are people terribly angry
about in a beautiful country or a high
level of prosperity but yet there's a
rabid et to popular discourse that I
myself under invigorating that wasn't
the verb I expected at the end Alamo
juiced so in a second I wanna ask you
one final question and ask you to do a
little bit of vulgar politics and I want
to ask you what your thoughts are on
President Trump of course is the
lodestar pound which everyone apparently
it revolves these days but if you want
to hear David Berlin skis answer you
have to be a daily wire subscriber to
subscribe head on over to daily wire
calm click Subscribe make sense and you
can hear the end of our conversation
there well david Berlinski thank you so
much for stopping by his book is human
nature go check it out it should be
available everywhere right I mean Amazon
bookstores wherever you can get it and
they make great gifts they did christmas
is coming human nature david thanks so
much for stopping by I really appreciate
it you're very welcome
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy borin associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Manor post-production is supervised by
Alex singhara editing by Donovan Fowler
audios mix my mic Hiromi no hair and
makeup is by Jesuit alvera title
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20